yeah it's time to do our clap
[Music]
everybody Welcome to the premiere the
very first the maiden voyage of the
Drew's News podcast we'll be giving you
all the fun quirky inspiring and yes
informative stories that exist out in
the world because well we all need it
right now and today we're covering
everything from a new dog breaking up a
Hollywood couple to the male nipple
having a moment and boy do I know how to
kick things off right
if there was a dream it's being realized
right now not only am I getting to hang
out with someone I've known since I was
around eight or nine years old but
someone that if I said I admire him it
would be the understatement of my life
he has been a friend he has been someone
that I highly respect both as a human
being and a professional
ladies and gentlemen I can't believe I'm
actually getting to launch this podcast
with another none other than Rob Lowe
Drew Drew I I am so honored to be your
first guest I can't tell you
like if we're gonna launch let's launch
with you you know what I mean let's do
this right it's very important that
first guest I remember on this podcast
it was a big D that first guest man you
gotta You Gotta Throw Down I just hope
I'm up to the task you are and the fact
that I have known you my whole life when
I launched the show here people did they
got really big on that who's the first
guest like it's some bizarre measuring
contest or like a stamp of what's to
come I don't know there's so much
emphasis on it yes so I called up my two
girlfriends
Cameron Diaz and Lucy Liu and said would
you do the first show with me you are
people I've been through everything with
you're my dearest friends and yes we
also happen to do a professional
Endeavor that we're all very proud of
and anchors us but it's everything we've
been movie great movie great movie great
movie great movie great movie great
movie thank you for saying that Rob Lowe
who's been in many a great movies
okay well what is fun about this podcast
is we have a little bit of a spine which
is news it's pop culture it's
informative It's News you can use so are
you ready to dive in I'm in I'm in this
is I love this I I I love love love
doing a podcast that is that is more
timely Minds mine are meant to like you
can sit on the cat the they can sit in
the in your thing and you can listen to
them years from now but I've always
wanted to do one that was time sensitive
and now I'm on one well in your podcast
that I was fortunate enough to just do
you helped me realize that we actually
live in a more gentle society when it
comes to divorce and how to cope and how
to not judge it and how to move forward
with togetherness and that that's more
acceptable and more supported and more
enabled now than it was back in the day
and I am feeling really optimistic about
life I'm happy to have helped in any
small way you really did
um okay so for first story up male
nipple
the male nipple is trending rob it is
all the rage and fashion right now it's
on display designers are creating looks
with nip slips if you will on purpose
and I might say you did have yours out
and about recently with your two sons
it's everywhere it's viral it's trending
by the way if anybody needs a visual on
this go to our IG at the Drew Barrymore
show.com to clock what we're talking
about so I think the the photo you're
referring to is my boys and I on the
back of a boat uh vacationing last week
and
um talk about timely right I was like
you know free the nipple
but that's the thing I say you know I I
bring my nipples on vacation with me I
do I bring them they're not staying at
home
and and sometimes and listen by the way
it's the south of France where we were
oh nothing but you know that's where you
let that's isn't that the land of being
topless I mean why you know equal for
everybody let's go I don't know because
I went to Italy with my two daughters
and got Paparazzi in my bathing suit and
I've never felt more vulnerable I looked
like a sheep that had just been walled
in five degree weather I mean when I
found out that there was pictures on The
Daily Mail of me in a bathing suit with
my cottage cheese and my two kids I I
literally think organs fell out of my
body I was like
did they catch me eating too like mid
bite looking like I was deep throating a
burger like at the same time was I
picking my nose like what else can we
just show like I felt so vulnerable but
it's funny because you know there's
plenty of women out there who feel like
free the nipple what's the difference
between free the nipple for a man and
free the nipple for a woman rob you got
me
um I mean you you really really got me
I'm I want to see what the new looks
that designers are making for guys are
very excited about it there are shirts
literally cut out to feature the nipple
this is sweet this is a shirt okay wait
I'm just trying to figure out so it's a
I'm wearing it is if this t-shirt I'm
wearing now had a nipple hole or is it
like a white like a like one of those
Italian undergarment things where you
know you can kind what are we talking
about I almost like a lightning bolt
like a lightning bolt has been cut out
of the shirt too drape and hands so that
your nipple is out and it's purposeful
but listen this is all feeling very
hairy styles to me right which is by the
way a great thing because that guy's a
stud and I love him but it I think do
you think I don't know I'm at an age
where I don't think I can pull it off my
sons can for sure
well I'm looking and I disagree
okay
next story
um it's about staying grounded in the
world of Hollywood which is so much of
what we talked about on your podcast do
we know how hard that is Rob I think we
do stranger things actor Noah schnapp
worked as a lifeguard this summer before
going to college quote to stay grounded
he was thrust into the world view at 11
years old when stranger things became a
worldwide phenomenon Rob thoughts been
there I mean listen I I think you take
the cake on this one eight years old E.T
doesn't get any bigger than that
um by the way you're so good in that
movie thank you that movie is
just it just I mean look I think every
ET should be the new Wizard of Oz it
should be on TV every year at Christmas
or whatever and we should all have like
remember like that's what we did we all
watched The Wizard of Oz it should be
E.T and you're spectacular in it
spectacular thank you for saying that I
mean
on your podcast we talked about the fact
that when I came onto the scene
so to speak when I walked out of the
house and the world became Technicolor
while The Wizard of Oz metaphor yes I
was seven it was 1982. and
I was a kid so I didn't have like girls
screaming for me there was no sort of
sexualized aspect however then my mom
took me to all the clubs I was around
adults I was definitely engaging in you
know in the early 80s it was Heavy
Hedonism we were coming out of the late
70s there was sex drugs and rock and
roll everywhere so I was too aware of
like sexualized things but I wasn't a
sexualized person you right were
literally a heartthrob that's one word
we haven't covered today we've done hunk
we've done stud
um you were the ultimate heartthrob and
that's an element in it that I just I I
I just still don't know how you managed
to it's a weird thing say a normal
level-headed person okay it doesn't
happen to everybody
and it's like a weird
it's like being in Jimmy Kimmel's
handsome men's club like like my theory
is every five years maybe it's ten
probably more now because everything's
sped up in the old days it was every 10
years every decade every five years
there's a new IT guy you know they all
in it and it everybody has who's the IT
guy has the same experience
it's it's that Madness that you're
describing and and you know what what
I've come to learn about it is it has
very little to do with with with with
you and so you shouldn't take any of it
personally good or bad it's just you
happen to be the guy who's the IT guy at
this moment and in 10 years there'll be
somebody else
I wish that perspective on every it guy
who ever lived or is to come in fact who
would you say is the IT guy now Rob well
for sure it's I know who it is and it's
it's it's somebody who's
had it it went away and now it's it's
he's he's back at it again and it's
Harry Styles
I feel like Harry is the IT guy he's a
little older I obviously was the Biebs
for Justin Bieber for for a long time
but my sons who are much more plugged in
would tell me would probably tell me
that there's somebody even younger and
and more on the Forefront but but from
where I said it feels a lot like it's
it's it's hairy now Harry Styles and you
also have that similar like boyish that
yummy that like pretty as well as sexy
and handsome you know how like that's
sexy or cute or funny and sexy like
there's like that four quadrants and
you're two of each like you guys are
everything like do you when you see
Harry Styles having lived a life you did
are you like have the most fun with this
like what what crosses your mind oh well
it makes me wish I had been a rock star
if you go back and Google Rob Lowe in
the 80s you'll see that I was dressing
like one oh total saxophone player when
funny when I first met my wife Cheryl
one of the first things she did was went
into my closet and and threw out all of
those clothes and made me start dressing
like a man and and I'll never forget her
line I didn't even know what this meant
at the time she goes no man should ever
wear an Eisenhower jacket
what is an Eisenhower jacket it's a
specific it's a cut of a jacket where
it's like cut super super high and it
made me laugh that she that that I was
wearing apparently Eisenhower jackets
but I thought it was like I wanted to be
like you know Roger uh Roger Taylor John
Taylor from Duran Duran but there was a
Roger Taylor too he was the drummer and
he's he's a friend of mine from Queen
Roger Taylor good friend no relation
John Taylor there was John Andy Simon I
was obsessed because it's true like I I
don't think that I've ever really looked
at like manly men and been like um I
always liked a boy who had like a wink
and a smile there was yes something not
so aggressively like masculine and yet
you're all man like I there's nothing
not masculine about you again refer to
this picture of you and your sons you
are three beautiful handsome men but
it's just it's so interesting okay Harry
Styles I I agree with that and by the
way before we move on from my boys
um so the John Owen who's pictured there
um it wrote
a a show for Netflix it got picked up
guess who his co-creator along with me
his co-creator for the show Victor
fresco
I was fortunate enough to do a show
called Santa Clarita diet with and the
the show is really all him like if you
if you like it it's all his fault if you
don't like it a lot of it is his fault
like he that was oh Victor Fresco and
you know he used to write on Max
Headroom no way I didn't know that and
um or or like Alf I think he definitely
wrote on out yeah he's he's super
talented but he loves you we talk about
you all the time but I wanted to make
sure you knew that so you watch when it
comes out on Netflix and don't know when
probably April well you must be so proud
yeah it's fun to work with your son oh
my God it's like all we want is for our
kids to end up okay yeah all right well
we have to cut to a quick commercial and
we'll be right back after this break to
serve you more news including a story
about a pet that caused a Hollywood
breakup oh you are not going to want to
miss this
[Music]
we're back okay our next story an
inventive teacher took action against
students using smartphones to cheat by
sneaking away to the bathroom during
exams the teacher exposed 14 cheating
students they put an impossible question
on the exam and secretly posted the
answer on a bogus website so the correct
answer could only be answered with a
Google Search and Bam the 14 students
who got it correct were caught red
handed uh Rob thoughts uh I was such a
little nerd in school Drew I I was
scared to ditch class
I was I was such a Midwestern teacher's
pet
sat in the front row hand up for every
question I would have been so scared to
cheat I I was I was I I was I just can't
imagine but I get it I totally get it
were was there a point where because I
did not know that about you yeah sad but
true or good but true depending on your
no good but true very sweet was there a
point where that changed and like
you got more in touch with your naughty
side
oh yeah I mean only just give me some
Fame and alcohol in the 1980s and I'll
take care of all the naughtiness you
want but um uh I think that actually in
in all seriousness is part of it is I I
was such a quote-unquote good boy that
you know and you know the thing is if we
if we can't not to get too serious but
if we can't integrate our IDs into into
our lives you're you're asking it's
going to come out
it's coming out and it may come out in a
way you don't like so we have to
integrate our shadow sides into our
light sides and and you know I granted I
was young so you don't really do that
but um it's super important to be aware
that we all have that in us I was always
so hedonistic you know and now by the
way it might be Freud's triangle that
like Keeps Us aligned because I know to
stay out of the ego the superego is fun
and I have a heavy ID
um and by the way you just sing I have a
heavy ID there's something about that I
really liked thank you well I I mean we
but like when you have access to
everything drugs partying backstory
passes you know backstage like just all
access pass everywhere you go to
everything and you're young
how is that not gonna like have to have
you figure some things out at some point
like did any one of us
I mean we made it out alive and we
thrived but like did anyone get a clear
pass and was like nope oh totally came
out perfect yeah nobody no one does and
and I think it's
you know those of us in in every Walk of
Life whether forget Show Business
anybody anybody anywhere or you know if
you're if you're not able to grow and
learn and adjust and and look at
yourself and look at yourself honestly
and look at your failings honestly then
you're not going to change you're not
gonna grow and then you will be stucked
and then you will be effed
I agree
and I definitely have like two
like cataclysmic moments where I
realized I needed to change one was when
my mom threw me in that institution and
another was after I got divorced I was
so broken that I just didn't know how to
pick myself up again I wanted to be
there for my kids but I was not there
for myself and I was a shell of a human
being and those were my two biggest
turning points and it's funny what the
turning points can be they can be what
you've described are big ones and you
know for other people they can be small
ones
um yeah mine was
I mean my Mom calling me in the days
when they had answering machines
and and leaving a message saying that my
favorite grandfather was in the hospital
had a heart attack and she needed me to
pick up the phone and I couldn't because
I'd been partying too hard and I didn't
want to talk to her
and I had that moment of this is
unsustainable this isn't who I want to
be this isn't who I am and that was the
last time I ever had a drink or a drug
was 32 years ago but it's good it's D
everybody has a different alarm clock is
what I'm saying and yet
um I also don't regret anything no for
sure no The Best Time Ever Ever hello
love my life people are like oh that I'm
like no not at all oh yes
you're like do you regret do you agree
here's the thing it's really I don't
regret anything you know that's one
thing even the stuff that blew up in my
face because if if I don't do that maybe
I'm not where I am today and I and I
really like where I am today everything
that blew up in my face is spot on to my
trajectory of all my happiness total one
billion percent and I had one hell of a
good time you and how about the memories
and the stories I'm
they're my most prize but other than my
my family literally other than my family
my most prized possessions are my
memories and stories like I said being
at your was it your 20th birthday party
at the lossa club the loss of Club God
bless you for remembering that I'll
never forget getting in there having the
best time it was one of the best nights
of my life and you had invited me and it
just seems like weirdly yesterday it's
extremely Vivid all right moving on
listen divorce is no laughing matter as
we've much established and can really be
tough on a family and there are so many
things that can be at the root cause but
this particular reason that this couple
is saying uh is new for me Sylvester
Stallone's wife model Jennifer Flavin
reportedly filed for divorce after the
couple disengaged over whether or not to
get a new dog Sly did say this wasn't
the only reason but they did disagree
over the best way to care for Dwight the
new dog the rocky actor also recently
tattooed a tribute to his late dog
Butkus on his bicep covering a previous
tattoo of his wife Jennifer flavin's
face so to me that sounds like why
there's a divorce
I mean that the dog over the tattoo and
the dog being yeah you know I never
thought the tattoo of Jennifer is
particularly good anyway so I blew a dog
on it you know let's put it in you do it
I think a lot of people like dogs I do
I am dying that is gonna live rent free
in my head on a broken record and I'm
gonna be the happiest person ever also
fun fact I do send almost one Rocky
giphy every single day of my life oh the
best it's either him doing the
one-handed uh you know uh oh God I'm so
bad at working out terms um push-ups the
one-handed push-ups or the like rolling
with the crowd or like ducking through
the meat you know the 80s in the 80s uh
there was a Santa there was a gym in
Santa Monica that everybody worked out
at and I was working out there and Sly
was there
training for Rambo now I don't look he
was always shredded in all these Rambo 2
was next level and then Rambo he used to
watch him work out and I would say
what's the secret what what should I do
because you got to be working on you you
show muscles I mean you wanna your
forearms because you just roll your
shirt down like that and everybody's
easier forever they think well
everything's really big you know just in
the woods and uh you know that and then
you know your absolutely do that who
loves but uh really that's gonna lose
you know much to sly's point at this
point I'm showing a quarter inch of
decolletage and forearm so I have to
agree all right our last story and it's
a sweet one you could get paid to eat
candy as the Canadian company's Chief
candy officer the position pays 100 000
Canadian dollars that's 78 000 American
annually besides eating about 113 pieces
of candy a day the chief candy officer
will lead the company's fun house candy
strategy run candy board meetings and
have a say in which product candy fun
houses will carry Rob would this be a
job that is in your dreams or your
nightmares well I just want to know what
they do every day when he has the sugar
crash yeah
I mean that because like I'm sure that
whoever has this job is going to be
great at it for about what 12 minutes
after he eats the candy and then it's a
nap and yeah for me it would be what's
the candy there are certain candies I
could eat all day and all day and all
night but other candies like I couldn't
do
think that children because I know when
my kids eat a lot of candy how psychotic
they act afterwards like you say the
crash do you think adults have that same
crash or do we grow bigger and like it's
different I I don't know the answer I
can tell you we do but here's what I
want to ask you
as a I remember there's that age where
we're all super concerned about our kids
sugar levels and it kind of that kind of
goes away well it goes away when we're
become concerned about their alcohol
levels
for sure I'm like my kids have
Barrymore's in their genes I'm terrified
yeah exactly it's like the having the
Irish Gene so they're Irish and
Barrymore's I'm double Downing on hell
but remember so when you're worried
about your kids having too much desserts
and too much sugar I always knew there
was trouble when a kid would come over
and say my parents don't let me have
sugar I knew I would find that kid
hopping sugar I you I just knew it I
knew beware the kid
who tells you the parents quote what
don't let him have sugar keep your eye
on that kid by the way you're so right
you're so right because my mom wouldn't
let me eat sugar Studio 54. but no show
Weed and Alcohol totally fine but don't
touch that sugar that makes perfect
sense and I did I snuck chocolate in the
closet yes under the bed for sure all
the other habits were out in the open
but the sugar was an in the closet thing
oh yeah I guess literally I would hide
it in a box in my closet and just
and then make my Barbies dry hump
so good
113 pieces of candy a day what candy
would you pick as your poison
um
um it would be it might be oh I was
gonna say Reese's Pieces in honor of you
and E.T oh my God you were about to say
buttercups I was I would no it was it
was it it's Reese's the old school
Reese's not the Reese's Pieces the old
school ones the little cups yeah that
was mine too really yes I pre-set it
Witnesses right here
but we we love Freud's triangle I know
and Reese's buttercups we sure do we
grew up in this industry and in this
beautiful job of ours that we're still
lucky enough to have maintained
we've lived lives that we Embrace
everything we've done and somehow we've
become family first people with
allergies to the fabulous Lane of Life
wanting our truest nearest and dearest
not because we are movers and shakers
but because they are the people that
bring out our best in US probably kick
our butts when we're not being our best
and who we feel most at home with that
to me is family totally I have loved you
for literally what will be in a few
months 40 years as a friend and someone
I know I loved you long before we met
that's how we met is because you were my
favorite and my hero and then we got
brought together because all I ever
talked about was you that was amazing
but that doesn't mean if you love
somebody that they're ever gonna like
show up in your life and you did
when I had the chickenpox and you became
my friend and invited me to your
birthday party and the rest is history
I love you I love your family
your beautiful wife Cheryl and your
gorgeous Sons I just wish you the best
and I can't thank you enough for
kicking this endeavor off with me
um well I thank you this is an honor
this is a great your show is fantastic
you're going into year three you're
killing it and now this podcast Drew's
news I'm here I am I'm I'm the headline
of Drew's news and that made my day and
week and Year by the way and ready
I love you thank you so much thank you
love you if you enjoyed this episode of
Drew's news podcast you can hear all new
episodes every Friday on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts
[Music]
foreign